[Music]
it's time for the launching horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn genes good evening this is
frank night may I introduce mr. William
Bradford Huie noted author and analyst
and editor-in-chief of the lone gene
Khurana scope and mr. carl hess pressed
editor of newsweek magazine our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable Harold Velde a United
States congressman from Illinois and
chairman of the unamerican Activities
Committee mr. Billy it's a pleasure to
welcome you to the krona scope again and
our viewers of course know you as
chairman of the rather highly
controversial house on American
Activities Committee and tonight we'd
like you to tell us something about your
plans for 1953 what will be your first
area of investigation well mister UA and
mr. hiss I want to assure you first of
all it is a great pleasure to be on your
very fine program again as to the first
area of investigation I believe and I
think the rest of the members the
committee concur with me in this then
our first duty is to weed out the
Communists and fellow travelers and
pinkos is there properly known from the
executive branch of government any
particular partner well primarily the
State Department and the Department of
Defense and of course after we are able
to do the
I think the next important thing is to
act as a watchdog committee to see that
no commies or other server sees of any
kind infiltrate the new Eisenhower
administration the first thing I suppose
is say you're aimed at the at the
holdovers the people who were in a print
in the previous administration who
haven't yet been discharged from
government yes naturally a mr. you a
it's going to take quite a long while to
change over the control of the executive
department of government is going to be
a gradual process now so you you
mentioned that you've been investigating
the State Department I think is fairly
well known but you mentioned the Defense
Department now are you directing a major
investigating effort at the Defense
Department now at the present time there
is one subpoena out for a very important
witness in the Department of Defense and
of course it's impossible for me to say
anything more about that at this time
but we do expect to show that several of
the people in the last administration
and were very close to being communists
and very close to the Soviet government
do you feel that any of them had a part
in influence and policy well certainly I
do and
I believe that we will be able to prove
that eventually important policy in the
Defense Department yes I think important
policy in defense and you think these
people had access to to secret
information in the Defense Department I
do believe that is true we have had of
course in the past investigations into
the Defense Department we've had the
investigations and the Signal Corps
intelligence department and we've had
other investigations well of course as
you perhaps remember we had general
Walter beetle Smith a head of the CIA
who in Philadelphia said that he could
give us some testimony in executive
session it is a closed session that he
couldn't possibly give us in the open
session with who are having at that time
so we have had some investigations into
the Defense Department which leads us to
believe that while it isn't extremely
serious it's something that we have to
give our attention to and weed it out or
it goes anywhere you anticipate taking
up for example the remark that even the
CIA has been infiltrated well certainly
certainly by the CIA you mean the
Central Intelligence Agency yes that's
right now sir one of the you say that
you want to protect the new Eisenhower
administration from subversives do you
expect to get a higher degree of
cooperation from the Eisenhower
administration than you got from the
Truman administration certainly but when
I say that to protect the Eisenhower
administration I don't mean that in a
political way I think the protection of
the Eisenhower administration will
certainly be a protection of the
American people but actually we do
expect to as we in Congress in the
legislative branch do expect to get a
lot more cooperation from the executive
branch sending and
specifically on the matter of I remember
that our viewers will remember that
President Truman repeatedly refused to
turn over to you certain executive files
now do you think that President
Eisenhower will make those executive
files available to you
yes but understand I don't believe that
President Eisenhower mr. J Edgar Hoover
mr. Brownell or any of the cabinet heads
should give all of their information to
the legislative branch there is certain
all that you'd asked for well I
personally would not ask for anything
that I didn't think they could give what
I'm referring to is the loyalty files of
the various departments in the executive
branch I believe that you have access to
those now the committee itself of course
is that a as I say a very controversial
career from the days that Martin dies
was its first chairman now do you feel
that the committee today has a a degree
of public support that it's never had
yes I do
from all of the letters that come into
our committee and they come in at the
rate of a few thousand a day we have by
far great majority and I would just
guess about 90% of them are favorable to
the work that the unamerican Activities
Committee has been what do we what
problem do you still have in public
acceptance of the work if any problems
well there are always a lot of people
who will never accept any a program that
we undertake because it might affect
them in what do you have
a lot of black wingers a lot of
fellow-travellers a lot of pinkos will
object to anything we do regardless of
what it is what about what about money
does your committee spend more money
than any other committee in Congress
yes we do well it was the smallest
committee in membership we only have
nine members on the unamerican
Activities Committee we have a staff
that numbers into the 50s and our
appropriation which we're going to ask
for this year is 300,000 that's more
than last year is it yes it's just
$15,000 more than we use last year
however and the other Committees of
Congress do not have the same problem
that was presented to us they need to
keep the extensive files as we keep and
I want to say here now that all of our
files are open to inspection by the
various intelligence agencies of the
executive branch when you maintain eyes
on with them
certainly we do and we intend to
continue maintaining that liaison with
them and well we are cooperating with in
addition to your investigation of the
Defense Department I believe that it's a
most controversial thing you are about
to do is some investigation of
subversive alleged subversive activities
in the colleges do you expect to get
around to the educational system this
year yes some of the first witnesses we
will call will be professors and people
who are interested in education I want
to say that by and large we have had the
cooperation of a great number of
universities and colleges throughout the
country they want to know whether there
is any subversive influences operating
in there
individual colleges and universities but
what about the objection to loyalty of
soon university well there is a
considerable an objection to loyalty
oaths it's brought about largely by the
American Association of University
Professors I believe which is a very
close organization they may have some
reason to object to loyalty oaths but I
believe that when we have completed our
investigation and have our hearings and
I'm very firm in this that they allow
the people who have had objection to
signing the loyalty oath will no longer
have are these loyalty oaths a workable
efficient - what exactly do they achieve
in university well in England certainly
when a person signs a loyalty oath which
is somewhat similar to a not a
non-communist affidavit under the tenets
Hartley Act law he's going to think
twice before he signs that oath prepare
being prosecuted for perjury before he
signed it now so you were with the FBI
before you went to Congress yes I wasn't
the FBI visualizing sabotage well mostly
in espionage activities Soviet espionage
activities do you feel that there is
more or less communist activity in the
United States today is it growing or is
it
unless I believe the actual communist
activity has become less in the past
several years than it has been
or since night military quantity well
that's in quantity and possibly not in
quantity there's still a very real an
immediate danger of the infiltration
Communist Party members of course who
are controlled by the Soviet in our
various fields from you institutions and
on your investigation of education you
feel that you will have the cooperation
of most of the educational institutions
or do you think the teachers
organizations will will resist your
investigation on the one you've met well
certainly I think that we will have the
cooperation of the great majority of our
educational institutions but I want to
say first of all that we're not kind of
trading on any one individual
institution except those direct
communist schools for instance the
lincoln schools the california labor
school the Jefferson School all of the
schools which largely teach labor and
communism directly and under direct
influence of the Communist Party and and
has a final question sir you don't feel
that that you are going to violate civil
rights in this investigation well there
is a possibility that we might in some
cases at least it might be made to
appear that we are violating civil
rights especially
it'll be need to hear that we're by the
communists ourselves well thank you very
much for being with us this evening sir
and pleasure I'm sure the opinions that
you've heard our speakers expressed
tonight have been entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Chronos cope was mister
william bradford chewy and mr. carl s
our distinguished guests was the
honorable Harold weld a United States
congressman from Illinois and chairman
of the unamerican Activities Committee
how would you go about hiring a man for
an important job well in a man or in a
watch the record of past performance is
the only yardstick to real value that's
why so many sensible people own
launching watches the honours which
launched in watts as f1 are a record of
fast performance these world's fair
grand prizes and gold medals each our
highest award were bestowed by many men
in many lands at many times observatory
accuracy Awards won just yesterday so to
speak are also part of the lawn gene
record from the record there could be no
doubt that lawn gene washes are above
than beyond the ordinary for almost a
hundred years lawn gene has been shown
to be close to the finest watch in all
the world by every standard beauty
integrity of manufacture accuracy and
reliability of performance the lawn gene
record made launching the world's most
honored watch the world's most honored
gift lawn gene premier product of the
lawn gene with noir watts company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene Chronos code
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored long gene
this is frank night reminding you that
long jean and wit nor watches are sold
and serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblem agency for
long jean wit nor watches
[Music]
it's time for the launching cornerstone
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour short show you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronicle mr. William Bradford
Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
Henry Hazlitt contributing editor of
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Hugh G Scott jr. United States
representative from Pennsylvania the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers congressman Scott is
former head of the Republican National
Committee and as one of the architects
of the Eisenhower campaign I'd like to
begin by asking you when's the campaign
going to start tomorrow
about the middle of the day I would say
Eisenhower makes an important speech in
Atlanta Georgia that will be followed by
speeches in other florida's in Florida
cities in Alabama in Arkansas and then
by very important foreign policy speech
in Philadelphia on the 4th of September
could you tell us what topics he's going
to speak on I on these first speeches
prior to the thought of his speech he
will talk generally on the mast in
Washington what he thinks about it with
some specific instances and I am quite
sure because I have some advanced
information that they will be very
forthright fighting speeches he agrees
with governor Stevenson that there is a
mess in Washington there well I'm sure
he agrees with government Stevenson that
there's a mess in Washington I'm sure
that he's very angry about it as a moral
fervor in the way in which he prepares
his speeches and I think we're going to
get the benefit of that his fate after
all as I see it is against Harry
Truman's bad government and Harry
Truman's captive candidate and Harry
Truman's having taken the leadership of
this campaign
Stephenson's a secondary issue and
Truman is a Milwaukee Labor Day speech
you recall as said in effect to
Stevenson watch how I do it I'm the boss
I run this thing and you take your lead
from me you think the battle from this
point on will be essentially between
President Truman and General Eisenhower
I think so because I don't think that
the Truman could keep out of it I don't
think that the issue of Truman ISM which
is equivalent to bad government could
possibly be kept out of it and I think
that mr. Truman's captive candidate is
just stuck with Harry you think that
there has been the feeling that that
General Eisenhower first could not
effectively make the case against the
Democratic Party and then second that
probably he would not make the case now
are you convinced her after your weeks
that you spent with him that General
Eisenhower is going to prosecute the
case against the Democratic Party yes
I'm satisfied he's going to prosecute
the case against the present
administration which goes under the
title of Democratic as if there's
nothing Democrat or Democratic about it
it's Truman ISM it's a mess that's the
best way or do you think that it's been
the statement that he would not resort
to personalities now that the president
has attacked him do you think that he
will at least resort to the prêt to the
personality of the president I think
that he can attack this whole thing
that's wrong without necessarily calling
anybody any bad names
because the bad odor and the bad
names have already been established I
think it's his job to point out what's
wrong with the government in power well
let's take one other personality namely
the Secretary of State I believe that
mr. Stevenson is on record as having
said that he didn't have the faintest
idea whether he would discharge mr.
Atchison or not do you think that
General Eisenhower has has something of
a firmer idea as to course of action
there I don't think there's a single
doubt in the world that if Dean Acheson
worse were stupid enough
well foolish enough to remain in office
next January that he would be fine I
have no question he'd be fired but I
think Addison will resign on the first
Wednesday after the first Tuesday of the
month but an American voter at least can
can make a choice on that point if he
has to choose Stevenson he doesn't know
whether he would get rid of Addison but
if he does mm our he knows he gets
adaptive and the victim of men who are
pretty smart
and among those men are Dean Acheson who
has controlled the foreign policy of
this country to its severe detriment the
man who has led us down the road to
weakness in the face of tyranny the man
who hasn't hesitated to deal with those
who are enemies of our government in a
weak-kneed mollycoddle milk and water
fashion the man has got to go and
Eisenhower there's no question you'd go
under Stevenson I don't think Stevenson
is is in the position where he can get
rid of these old men of the sea that
have been paying to the Democratic ship
well general Eisenhower has said that
some terrible blunders were made in
Korea in our getting into Korea now is
he going to spell out and detail what
those blunders were I'm quite sure that
he is going to spell them out because he
will make several speeches on foreign
policy and one of them inevitably more
than one would have to deal with the
kind of a war that we've gotten into
which we can neither win nor lose no
stop and when mr. Truman in his Labor
Day speech spoke of all those people who
had been
they did so much from as he said from a
higher wage I can think of 137 thousand
casualties in Korea who will never
benefit from anything that mr. Truman
has done he's General Eisenhower going
to defend the taft-hartley Act against
the attacks of Stevenson and of the
president I think that general
eisenhower would likely take the
position and I cannot undertake
obviously to speak for him but I would
believe that he would take the
Republican position which is that the
labor-management Act of 1947 operates
fairly in the interest of people who who
are in labor union labor or non-union
labor I think again mr. Truman has given
us the key to it but he points out that
union labor used to have three million
people since the labor-management act or
the taft-hartley Act of 1947 there are
now 16 million people in unions all of
them not have paid all of them of better
living conditions the taft-hartley Act
has been a good at a beneficent Act and
it has worked to the advantage of labor
how the majority of Democrats in
Congress think about these attacks on
the taft-hartley Act didn't the majority
both of the house and of the Senate vote
for the taft-hartley Act I'm speaking of
the Democratic majority mr. Hayes my
recollection that they did yes I think
they did and didn't they also a majority
in Congress also recommend or express
the hope that the president would use
the taft-hartley act in the steel strike
of course of course they did and more
than that you'll be interested in all
rather old incident the late chairman of
the House Labor Committee was mr.
Lozinski of Michigan mr. Rosinski on one
celebrated occasion said to one of the
Republican members of the committee we
are not going to do anything to repeal
taft-hartley or to change it because
we'd rather have it as an issue than do
anything about it and that's mr.
Truman's position and it necessarily has
to be mr. Stevenson's position if he
were to be the chief executive Mr Scott
a great deal has been
about eras in the Eisenhower campaign
thus far as one of the Eisenhower
strategists do you think that there have
been any errors in the other camp
well I of course always thank a wise
Providence for the Democratic National
Committee I think they've made quite a
few errors it must have been working
pretty hard at it in the short time
they've had the the cabinet meeting
which showed that Stevenson was called
to Washington to get his orders from
Harry was one instance of it that showed
that the hand the hand of the voice is
the voice of Jacob but the hand is the
hand of Esau and you remember that was a
hairy hand the same thing true the voice
is the voice of it adlai the hand is
Harry well now on our program last week
mr. Jim Farley made some rather critical
statements about the Eisenhower campaign
before you go on mr. Huey I I didn't
want to mention another blunder and that
was the fact that mr. Stevenson admits
that there's a mess in Washington now
he's going to try to back away from it
but he said it and he's good at these
six syllable words but he stumbled all
that that will fall out a word mess and
he's wallet at home and mr. Farley
however made some definite predictions
as stan has he has some reputation as a
predictor I believe and we'd like
tonight I'm sure that our viewers would
like you to predict somewhat the way
that you think the campaign will develop
in the way the nation will vote well if
you think Eisenhower specifically has a
chance to get into southern states well
I'm not in the Jim Foley's that League
as a predictor but I did predict that
Eisenhower would lead his opponent on
the first ballot by a hundred votes and
I predicted it to newspaper men a month
beforehand I only missed it by five
votes I I would say that if I may
venture in mr. Farley's feel that
Eisenhower will win that he will carry
several southern states that he will
have the support of
all groups and classes and kinds and
conditions of Americans because he's not
a sectarian or a sectional candidate you
can take the National candidate you can
name the southern states that you think
General Eisenhower can carry I think it
might be unfair to those people who are
working so hard in all the southern
states to point the finger it's commonly
said that among those are Virginia Texas
I would think that Louisiana with its
immense reaction against the tideland
situation would be one Florida and
others
well General Eisenhower take the
position of Texas on the tidelands case
or take position that chippers believes
in well I understand that that he has
substantially taken this position that
Texas had a treaty with the United
States Texas reserved the right to the
all of its lands including those
offshore and the United States or not to
break any treaty including one with
Texas the Texans don't like it either
they're awful mad about it I think but
then as I understand you sir
you were one of those supporters of
Eisenhower who is completely convinced
that the general will carry on a very
forthright slugging campaign from this
point yes I'm satisfied of it I reminded
Jim faller the other day that there's a
maximum which he may have invented that
you never campaigned in the straw hat
naturally those people who want
Eisenhower to win and there's so many of
them are anxious for him to get started
early but Labor Day is usually the start
of the campaign and you expect it to
start well thank you very much for being
with us tonight mr. skies the editorial
board for this edition of the launching
kkona scope was mr. William Bradford
Huie
and mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guests was the honorable Hugh D Scott
jr. United States representative from
Pennsylvania
north south east or west no other name
on a watch means so much as launching
the world's most honored watch actually
launching watches are sold and serviced
in all the capitals of the free world
for the appreciation of things fine and
beautiful is universal judging by the
same high standards millions of people
the world over agree that lawn gene
watches are in every respect worthy of
the 10 world's fair grand prizes and
twenty eight gold medals which impartial
juries of experts have bestowed upon
them for elegance and excellence it was
through superior merit that lawn gene
became in fact the world's most honored
watch now whichever launching watch you
choose to make your own rest assured it
will bring you in full measure the
greater accuracy and longer life for
which lawn gene watches our world on it
yet unbelievably you may buy and own or
buy and proudly give the long gene watch
for as little as seventy one fifty long
gene the world's most honored watch
premier products of the long gene with
nor wats company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
carrier
[Music]
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene Cronus code
a television journal of the important
issues of the are broadcast on behalf of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honoured launching this is
frank night reminding you that long gene
and wit nor Watson's are sold and
serviced from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this M Agency for long
gene with nor what
[Music]
the honored murdered wawk wawk wawk
is launching thawne gene watches have
won ten world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and more honors for
accuracy than any other timepiece
launching the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the long gene
with no watch company
it's time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Khurana scope mr. Henry
Steiger editor of our GC magazine and
mr. William Bradford Huie editor of the
american mercury our distinguished guest
for this evening is the honorable hugh d
scott jr. united states representative
from pennsylvania the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the speakers
mr. scott our audience of course knows
you as a man who's devoting a great deal
of time to promoting the candidacy of
general eisenhower
now obviously you think you're going to
have an active candidate so we won't ask
you those old questions about whether or
not you think is going to run but we
would be interested in your
interpretation of general of what you
think will be general Eisenhower's
positions now sir do you believe that
General Eisenhower expects to wage a an
active campaign and express his opinions
on all the vital issues I would
certainly expect that yes I I have heard
him say on occasion that when not in
uniform he would never have any
hesitation and expressing himself
vigorously on the issues of the day and
I've heard him used the expression the
American people will be in no doubt as
to where I stand on any important matter
you think that he's too good an American
to expect to be given the nomination
while the people are still in doubt as
to where he stands I think he would feel
that the American people are entitled to
know from not
his past speeches but from his future
comments exactly where he stands on
matters of grave importance and I think
that long before the time the people
will have to act they will be fully
aware of his views stated without
equivocation now there are many good
Americans who have bitterly opposed to
the candidacy of General Eisenhower see
now for instance let's take the their
their points that they make against him
number one they say that he has no
stomach for controversy what's your
opinion on that suit well I think that's
about as ridiculous as any statement
I've ever heard because to know general
Eisenhower's to know that he has never
hesitated to lay down the law to express
his opinions as he sees them I know of
some of the things he's had to say to
foreign governments I know of one
celebrated difference of opinion with
Churchill for example and now there's
nothing wrong with that man what about
Donald water
speaking of intestinal fortitude how
about such ordinary everyday things as
we've even heard talk about his weak
stomach literally speaking well I was
there one day when some gentleman had
just spread that unworthy sort of smear
and he said to me the only thing that
has bothered me the whole time I've been
in Europe has been the fact this morning
I have a cold in the head and that day
in the afternoon he played 18 holes of
golf
it's his custom to work eight hours to
play golf afterwards if time permits and
often to work after that certainly he's
a strong and virile and healthy man well
now let's take the one about his having
restrained General Patton his heavy
generally approved the cooperate with
Russia policy in 1945-46
is having supported the morgenthau plan'
now do you believe that general
eisenhower favored the cooperate with
russia plan in 1945 and six well on the
contrary i would be inclined very
strongly to believe what you will find
for yourself in the Forrestal Diaries
page 76
ladies and gentlemen page 264 and 265
where it shows that the wherefores tour
reports that Eisenhower very definitely
came to grips with Churchill that he
complained against the fixing of that
line that he wanted to proceed as far as
our military potential will permit and
then another thing occurs in another
place in the Forrestal Diaries he
expressed grave mistrust of giving any
concession away to the Russians at the
forthcoming yoga conference and said to
Churchill I hope you will not make major
concessions to the Russians because they
can't be trusted how about specifically
the a-bomb mr. Scott
there was some talk you know about
sharing that with Russia at the time
around 1945 what was this what was his
thought there I I could not answer my
own knowledge because I'm not familiar
with the controversy but I do know that
his general distrust of communism his
hatred of communism and his distrust of
Russia would never have allowed
generalizing how to concede for a moment
that the a-bomb ought to be shared with
Russia and I've heard of his views in
the Korean War where he is reluctant to
use it as a military weapon unless and
until there is no other alternative
now let's you mentioned Yalta a moment
ago sir now number one it's your opinion
that general eisenhower was consulted
before the Yalta Conference it's my
opinion that he was consulted generally
on military and diplomatic matters and
that he did express himself as forests
or reports that he did as being very
mistrustful of the Russians and hope
enjoy it would be your opinion that he
would have been opposed to the
concessions made by President Roosevelt
to Russia at Yalta oh I would very
definitely feel that and I and I know
from very recent conversations how much
he hates and fears communism and how
anxious he is that the American people
and especially the young people will
become aware of the dreadful in the
awful Menace which communism is it's
your belief that he understands the
nature of the Communist conspiracy
throughout the world and that he was no
other man does mr. Helius no other man
does in my opinion and I think he is the
foremost fighter for the American Way of
life of the Democratic way for the way
of the collective security of the free
peoples that I own to the scene here in
the United States it's often been said
that is being favored by the Truman
administration on so many occasions
might be the kiss of death how do you
feel about that
well I've seen a letter which the
general wrote to someone on the first
name basis not so long ago in which he
said I have never been responsible for
nor assumed responsibility for the
policies of any administration any
administration during the 40 years in
which I've been in the army most
American think that's the answer to that
surely I know that he's praetor to
combat the things with which he
disagrees nut would include a lot of
Truman ISM and he's a he's a highly
honorable man of great integrity and he
certainly wouldn't go along with this
shabby corruption that we are suffering
today what about our Asiatic policy and
specifically mr. Atchison do you think
you'd have any enthusiasm for mr. Atta
said I I don't know his personal opinion
but I don't see how he could go along
with the Asiatic policy and I know many
of the strongest critics of the Asiatic
policy who have talked to the general
and then expressed themselves as
entirely satisfied with Ike Eisenhower
use on the Asiatic Paulo now most people
who
he wouldn't favor any truck looking
toward communism money any appeasement
most Americans who are anti
administration's they won't a battle in
1952 they think that they lost to Truman
in 1948 because they didn't have a
scrapping candidate now is it your
conviction sir that if they nominate
General Eisenhower they will get a real
scrapping candidate another not another
meet to candidate listen I'd like to say
to you mr. Huey and to the people in
this television audience that if they
knew General Eisenhower as I know him
and as many other people who know him
better than I do are aware of there is
no question of the fact that there's
much that goes on in our government in
domestic and foreign affairs which he
will feel free to criticize which he
will criticize and if the people want to
fight by golly we'll give him to him
because there's an awful lot that I hate
about this administration and I think
that the generals views are those of a
good modern minded middle-of-the-road
Republican about the MacArthur fight and
I would expect him to do the same thing
you know there was a lot of talk about
Eisenhower and MacArthur being at odds
could you clear that up I'd like to know
how they feel about each other well I I
don't I can't obviously say how one man
feels about another it's in his mind I
don't know but I do know this that so
far as I have any information they both
hold each other in high regard and if
each of them thinks as much of the other
as I think of both of them well that can
be no cause for this faked controversy
which a few people would like to throw
out the gentleman gloss is a great man
then I Giessen how is a great man and
among great man I find a mutual respect
for that capacity
well if Eisenhower is such a fighting
man isn't he going to come out pretty
soon and and and state his candidacy and
Houston are we going to find out about
it I think that is a question but you're
only get going to get answered by
General MacArthur himself but I would
expect that long before the convention
he will be in civilian life again out of
uniform and free to answer these
questions how about some bout in
how about in March mr. Scott you know
we've got that wouldn't be a bit
surprised you got the New Hampshire
primary on Martel I'm in February it
could happen in March it will depend
upon the completion of his job I think
that most of our audience who would like
to be interested in your answer to this
question suppose General Eisenhower does
campaign for the Republican nomination
and suppose for some reason he loses it
do you think that he would then support
the Republican ticket in the campaign at
1952 I have said that I've entirely
convinced that he's a Republican
therefore I apply that standard I am
sure that no matter how we may differ
now that after the convention all of us
will be united to get rid of this vile
shabby mnestheus Truman ISM and I would
expect that any other Republican which
would include General Eisenhower in
civilian life would feel the same way
now do you think that general eisenhower
will get quotes the liberal support in
America you yourself consider yourself a
liberal as it's now used in American
politics well I I don't think that
either like Eisenhower myself would want
to use the word liberal unless we knew
what it meant I have a quotation from
him in which he said the definition of a
liberal has become a man in Washington
who wants to play the Almighty with our
money no he's not that kind of a liberal
I think he'd be very careful with the
pocketbook in the first stirrings of the
government ice if you mean a progressive
a modern minded middle-of-the-road
a mid-century American who shares the
apprehensions of other apprehensive
Americans yes I hope I'm that kind thank
you sir thank you so very much for
coming up the editorial board for this
edition of the launching Cronus Cove was
mr. Henry Steiger and mr. William
Bradford Huie our distinguished guests
was the honorable UD Scott Jr a United
States representative from Pennsylvania
four thousand leading jewelers in the
United States will answer your question
what is the finest watch you sell with
the answer my finest is Longy now isn't
that a compelling consideration when
planning the purchase of a watch as a
Christmas gift
as a matter of fact throughout the world
in such places as Athens storage seat of
learning Mecca religious center of the
Muslim world in Bangkok capital city of
Thailand the ancient Siam or in La Paz
the sky-high capital of Bolivia as in
all capitals of all the free nations no
other name on a Christmas watch means so
much as launching the world's most
honored watch the only watch in history
to win 10 world's fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medal awards and
highest honors for accuracy from the
great government observatories there's a
style and type of launch in watts for
every need and purpose faultlessly
finished styled with ageless good tastes
made with the skill of 85 years of fine
watchmaking experience to give good time
for a long long time and you know that
you may buy and proudly give a long gene
watch this Christmas for as little as
seventy one fifty
long gene the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the launching with
noir watts company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character this is Frank Knight again
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at this
same time for the long gene Collis code
the television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wet nor distinguished
companion to the world honored launching
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for lawn jean wit nor watches
[Music]
[Music]
the world on earth is long gene watches
have 110 world fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and more honors for
accuracy than any other timepiece
launching the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the Longy with
no watch company it's time for the
launching horoscope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our toilet
us for this edition of the Long team
Chronicle mr. William Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
Henry Hazlitt editor of the freeman and
contributing editor for Newsweek
magazine our distinguished guest for
this evening is the honorable john z
beamer united states congressman from
Indiana the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the figures
congressman Beamer you represent the
fifth District I believe in Indiana and
that is the home of women Otis who is
now a Texas Avakian prison in our finest
Gulf interest our Carlos audience is
gravely concerned about the fate of
Americans abroad and the treatment of
Americans abroad and I'd like you to
tell us some of the background of that
case the ask Mr hazard oldest came from
Marion Indiana which is in the fifth
congressional district that I had the
privilege to represent in fact Marion is
only twenty miles from my home town of
Baalbek which is
the banks the wabash in April of 25 this
last year the newspapers and the press
reportedly disappearance abilities and
admittedly I began to receive telephone
calls letters and telegrams from the
people in the district asking me to do
something before the disappearing
contagion disappearance in
Czechoslovakian sac team has been sent
over there as an Associated Press now
respondent learned that he was arrested
in the State Department I think was on
the following day the 26 reported that
he had been in prison and then it was
early in May that I introduced the
resolution in his behalf in fact I
introduced several relays resolutions
and had other members of Congress that
do like life now so this of course is
just another one of these Americans that
have been in effect grabbed as hostages
by the Russian satellite countries isn't
that correct
well yes mr. Yuri actually appeared to
us with the people back home after all
notice is just another person who was
being used
grafton hostage prep to use this for
ransom purposes or as many of us of
stuff to embarrass them to destroy the
difference in the United States yes it
because us there's a nation to lose face
in Europe and then just for trading
purposes the only case against him is
that he's an American seized by our
enemies to use for advantages against us
well of course they said he was fine
Nigel if he was spying he was really
getting new the same as any other news
reporter would be gathering and if he
was spying a lot of people in this
country could well they had a mockery of
a trial too didn't they a big yes they
had a trial in fact matters
the American embassy officials remember
to be able to see him Annie yes they
claimed they had a confession from him
well the chances are and the reporting
be quite true that he was tortured in
the usual methods of bringing a
confession from him were secured that in
that message by the way I might say that
at the trial the only two of America's
present were seated at the back into the
room and so we do have a transcript of
the trap which was taken in shorthand by
one of those secretaries but that was
actually charged against the merely was
that he was doing his duty as a
correspondent more or less and getting
the news wasn't that about it
that was from their point of view
however that must get the news directly
from their sources and published servers
of propaganda agent now that's not the
way we do the news live country well our
audience then can understand that here
is an American doing his duty in a
foreign country he suddenly seized and
thrown into jail and subjected to
torture now the question becomes what
can we do and what are we doing about it
say well bill I'd like to get the
congressman to tell us first of all
perhaps what the background was and what
actually has been done or has not been
done now Congress passed this resolution
of yours that is not X right and what
did that provide well this the
resolution which was House joint
concurrent resolution 140 express the
sense of Congress that they should sever
trade relations with Czechoslovakian
other words impose economic sanctions it
didn't have anything to do at that time
with the severance of diplomatic
relations yeah and if the State
Department do anything effective along
their lives
well they imply that what we might term
is illegal procedure going to the Joel
agreements on trade and tariffs which
didn't meet until September in Geneva
Switzerland and the fact family just to
secure the content of the signatory
nations to work with accepting the
satellite cars of course to sever their
relations with the text under the bring
the gondola grim on trade and tariffs I
might add by the way that they haven't
very much result as a better perspective
value in that result is at Otis's stella
prison area integrals of the sad thing
is and he's still there he's been there
since last April
yes now sir what can we do as a nation
what what could we do now you've
recommended in your in your resolution
one course of action what about the
severing diplomatic relations with these
people well at the time it was felt the
threats the better part of wisdom was
better part of valor was the wisdom that
might be displayed in having another
method to use another shall we say
another string to our bow in other words
if the economic sanctions that were
proposed by this resolution if they did
not produce the results and then that
proposal to introduce could be
introduced to several relations with
tsipras now and here and your efforts
are to get to the notices released
have you had the cooperation
satisfactory cooperation from the State
Department look frankly I have had the
eye field verb weak cooperation they
have stated that certain things have
been done rather nebulous terms and I
still can't to report to you what they
have reported to me fact the matter is
of course they did effect some changes
to the general agreement on trade and
tariffs but even so I want to point out
to you that in 1951 several months we
included matter when they could have
called relations the check still
imported more merchandise to the United
States there was imported entire year of
1949 and nearly as much as they imported
in 1950 so that has they maybe haven't
done much to let my actually the checks
now are asking or the tech communists
are asking for a form of ransom for
blackmail for the release of the oldest
aren't they
what does not to give turn they're
falling yes for example they they asked
one hundred and twenty thousand wasn't
it for the form twenty thousand dollars
as if for fires were put down in the and
hungry and
the water taste we had to make a trade
there had to make a trade I don't know
the amount with us but enormous amount
of course concessions Aaron he's been in
prison for 17 months and I believe this
is true sir I believe mr. Boger gives
credit for his release to the press and
to his wife and gives no credit to the
State Department for his release isn't
that correct great true in fact mr.
Bremen I had the pleasure of meeting and
spring and evening with mr. mrs. Robert
Hoover and he very infected says that
you must give credit Donnelly to mrs.
Wilkinson what untiring unceasingly for
his release but also to the press and
the radio of this country best labored
in his behalf
though congressman do you think the auto
pay ransom again for Otis as we did for
those other and for the four American
Flyers I would say emphatically no it
was a time and early history this
Republic when we were very small and we
did pay ransom introduced to the Pirates
and Barbary Coast
but even limb even then you remember the
president sent Decatur with a small
fleet of ships to put a stop to that
type of rig indeed I I think it's quite
beneath our dignity to you even
considered modulus well then I'd like to
ask this I'd like to turn this a human
question round about breaking off the
diplomatic relations for Czechoslovakia
and asked why should we continue such
relations what would get out of it out
outside of humiliation and insults and
and seizing and kidnapping of our
representatives there well may I repeat
the answer that's been given or a really
the reason that they have given me in
some instances they said that as long as
we have the diplomatic relations there
in the country we do have listening
posts but I question the validity of the
strength of that argument because I just
wonder how much they're getting or how
much they're succeeding in that so they
have listening posts here by the same
token haven't saying
bend over pretty still listeners didn't
put a mild turn for them not only that
they had access to everything they want
yeah they have access over there to
everything and you are they're very very
restricted extremely restricted and in
those countries all our representatives
are yes clear rich deep into the number
of employees they can have and anything
you've just stated to our listeners sir
that there are ways by which we could
hit them in the pocketbook that we are
not using isn't that correct
I feel like still one of the most
emphatic ways and stuff defer to affect
this thing as to step upon the possible
to the tech they need our American
dollars first of all or the well for
their weakened currency and they needed
to the propaganda purposes even perhaps
the same propaganda back here which
they're doing quite extensively I say
now sir our sense mr. Vogler says that
the only way he got out of Hungary was
because the American press and the
American people got him out suppose that
some of our listeners would like to help
get their Lotus out what can our
listeners do is it and if as a practical
matter the hell well there are a lot of
things practical do it isn't necessary
to write to me I'm working as long as I
can as much as I cannot appreciate what
as we received many of them
I wasted every person who was interested
in the indignities decided States and in
Bilitis the natural may I interrupt
middle this is more or less a simple
today and he isn't just a man anymore
he's a simple freedom of speech freedom
of press even print of a life I'd like
for every person to write to present to
women to Secretary of State adjusting
and insist that they take some positive
action rather than just a slap on the
wrist I'm sure that our audience is very
much appreciated this hearing of use
tonight sir and thank you for being with
us the editorial board for this edition
of the Long team Chronos go applause mr.
William Bradford Huie and
Henry Hazlitt our distinguished guests
was the honorable john z beamer united
states congressman from Indiana
the Winter Olympic Games recently
completed at Oslo were exclusively timed
by launching to 110 and the hundreds to
the second our award was this telegram
launching equipment used for all
timekeeping during the Winter Olympic
Games in 1952 all worked perfectly
thanks for your valuable cooperation
signs the organising committee now
that's a wonderful telegram and were all
ever so pleased flan Jean was actually
official watch for the three great
Olympic sports events of the year the
Winter Olympic Games at Oslo the third
Bolivarian games at Caracas in Venezuela
and the first ten American Games held in
Juarez and Argentina and now we're proud
to announce that the United States
Olympic Committee has selected long gene
watches for timing all events for this
election of the United States Olympic
team of 1952
so you see wherever precise timing is
important in sports aviation and science
the preeminent choice of watches is long
gene the only watch in history to win
ten world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and highest honors for
accuracy from the leading government
observatories long gene the world's most
honored watch premiere product through
the long gene with Norma's company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long gene coma scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and with noor distinguished
companion to the world on it long gene
this is frank night reminding you that
launching and which noir watches are
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for lawn jean with Norma
[Music]
the honored
wah-wah-wah-wah is long gone gene
watches have won ten world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other time
fees launching the world's most honored
watch is made and guaranteed by the lawn
gene with more watch company it's time
for the long gene promise cope a
television journal of the vital events
of they are brought to you three times
weekly a presentation of the lawn jean
wit nor watts company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chroma scope dr. Yan papinek
formerly ambassador from Czechoslovakia
and member of the Advisory Committee of
the United Nations and mr. William
Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury our
distinguished guests for this evening is
the honorable ok armstrong united states
congressman from Missouri in this
spontaneous and unrehearsed discussion
the opinions are necessarily those of
the speakers
congressman many of ours
listeners will remember you for your
splendid stories and articles in
Reader's Digest I believe you are you're
from the Missouri Ozarks aren't you
that's right mr. Dooley I live in
Springfield Missouri and that's right in
the middle of the Ozarks and you're a
Republican from that state - yes believe
it or not I'm a Republican well we've
got a progressive Republican I see
tonight sir we are an hour in our
listeners will be most interested and
what you're doing in Congress your
efforts to free the splendid American
journalist bill Otis now how did you
come to champion the mr. Otis well mr.
Huey being a journalist myself a former
newspaperman and magazine writer I was
attracted to the idea that something
should be done when the communist regime
of Czechoslovakia imprisoned this man
simply because as we felt that he was
going about his duty so I introduced an
amendment to a resolution in Congress
which called upon our government to cut
off trade relations with a communist
regime of Czechoslovakia unless he is
freed you are of course convinced of
that Otis is innocent of all the charges
that have been made against him oh yes
indeed and I'm sure the my colleagues in
Congress agree on that and what what
steps have have now been taken to free
mr. Otis well mr. UAM the resolution
which was passed by Congress calls upon
our government to break trade relations
with Czechoslovakia unless mr. Otis is
freed now that resolution was passed I
believe dr. papinek you recall the date
to the passage of that resolution it was
in
August 24th if I'm not mistaken well at
any rate doctor since that time
considerable pressure has been put on
the Czechoslovakian government as you
know to free this American newspaper
correspondent but unsuccessfully now we
think it is time to put in put all the
pressure that we can to get him freed
what particular steps have been taken
prior to your action sir prior to the
action of Congress on my resolution the
President the Secretary of State and
others in the executive departments had
made some moves to free mr. Otis those
moves were for the most part diplomatic
we felt or at least a great many of us
in Congress felt that they were just
slaps on the wrist they were not strong
enough
and therefore we went ahead with this
resolution now at the present time I
have introduced a new resolution which
would make the breaking off of trade
relations with Czechoslovakia mandatory
in other words they would be broken off
by congressional action now there have
been some other moves made for example
prohibiting the airplane traffic from
Prague the capital of Czechoslovakia and
other points in that country from flying
across the occupied zones of Germany
this I think is hurting them at least I
think it is what do you think doctor
definitely it is hurting them because
the direct connections with the West
that are very important by my air are
cut off as you - costing them money
costing them money very definitely and
they cannot contact the West the same
way as they could because most of the
other lines Americans and
others are stop their flights to
Czechoslovakia to why a doctor was Otis
seized in the first place was he seized
as a hostage of in my opinion just the
purpose was to help him as a hostage for
future purposes and that there are some
of those purposes what did they want
from us
what did they want to trade out is one
of the one of the reasons is that they
were complaining and are still
complaining of the broadcasts of The
Voice of America and the new broadcasts
that are developing from Munich directed
to Czechoslovakia and I see how it is to
intimidate harass or intimidate and
perhaps to free him if these broadcasts
would be stopped but congressman Hobbs
could I ask you whether your resolution
especially the second one as it is
proposed is or will be a part of the
general policy of the United States or
whether it is intended just for the
purpose of helping to free mr. Otis
well dr. papinek while the resolution is
directed at this specific case of
freeing this American citizen and
correspondent it is the sentiment of my
colleagues in Congress I am sure that
this be a test case and that it set a
precedent and that wherever in any of
the Iron Curtain countries under the
domination of the Soviet Union free
citizens are imprisoned unjustly that in
the future the read regime of that
government will be given notice that we
are going to take every step possible to
protect them I hope that the resolution
been adopted will cover every case and
that there would not be any exceptions
well that's exactly what we hope it will
do the resolution as you understand
calls for the cutting off
of exports from this country from the
United States to your fatherland to
Czechoslovakia by action of the Commerce
Department in other words the cutting
off of all permits to export goods from
this country likewise the Treasury
Department which has charge of imports
from Czechoslovakia to this country
would prohibit any transactions that
would permit trade from Czechoslovakia
to the United States so it would be a
complete blockade of trade either way
this policy when developed we will
affect tremendously the people of
Czechoslovakia whose morale will be
strengthened to resist the communist
regime is there strong resistance in
Czechoslovakia now doctor and definitely
there is I would say that over 90% of
the people oppose the regime but the
real fact that jails are full that there
are executions practically every week
that the forced labor camps are full of
about 300,000 people are there prove
that there is a resistance well I I'm
glad to hear your explanation of that
doctor because we in Congress and
certainly the American people do not
want to penalize the people of
Czechoslovakia we feel that they are the
victims of communist aggression however
we feel that if this step is taken and
those people of the resistance of the
underground the anti-communist forces in
Czechoslovakia they will be willing to
make whatever sacrifice is needed in
order to strike directly at the
communist regime is that they will be
happy to do so and they know also that
the economic relations trade relations
during the
months or last two years that have
developed really supported the Soviet
military buildup Conseco Slovakia
imported on the raw materials and now
congressman after all bill Otis is an
individual and what I'm interested in is
whether this is going to be effective in
getting the man out now to you when do
you think Otis will be released
well mr. joy that is the $64 question so
far as mr. Otis himself is concerned and
as you say he is a human and we want to
free him we do we do not want of course
but you cannot predict this just how
long he'll be imprisoned when do you
think he'll be released
Oh mr. Huey I believe when this blockade
becomes effective I believe that he will
be freed within a few weeks within three
or four weeks from now then you think
there's a good chance that Bill Otis
will be free I think there is a good
chance that he'll be free however I
think that he will be freed when Moscow
tells the red regime of Czechoslovakia
to free hell thank you so much for being
with us congressman the editorial board
for this edition of the launching
horoscope was dr. Yan papinek and mr.
William Bradford Huie our distinguished
guests was the honorable okay Armstrong
congressman from Missouri
one of the most interesting monuments in
New York is in Herald Square it's a
replica of the clock of medieval days
which was simply a striking mechanism
there was no dial no hands just tolling
bells to mark the time
[Music]
and way back in the distant past the
word watch was first applied to a
timepiece where the time could be read
rather than her and way back in 1866
that's 85 years ago the first lawn gene
watch was made created to the ideals
that forever and forever the name lawn
gene would be placed only on the finest
watches which mechanical skills could
produce how well successive generations
of lawn gene watchmakers have followed
this ideal is reflected by the public
honors lawn gene watches have won 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and highest honors for
accuracy from the leading government
observatories the lawn gene watch is now
being shown by fine jewelers throughout
the land reflect in every detail of
performance and beauty the perfection
which today's launching watches have
attained it's a fair statement that
throughout the world no other name on a
watch means so much as launching the
world's most honored watch premier
products of the lawn gene with nor wats
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
[Music]
this is frank night reminding you that
our program is brought to you three
times weekly Monday Wednesday and Friday
so once you join us again Wednesday
evening at this same time for the
launching promise code a television
journal of the vital events we are
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and quit norm
distinguished companion for the world
honored long gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for launching
with noir watches
it's time for the long gene horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Cronus code Larry no sir CBS
News correspondent and August texture
chief editorial writer for the New York
Herald Tribune our distinguished guest
for this evening is the reverend dr.
Edward L R Elson passed through the
National Presbyterian Church of
Washington DC during this Christmas Todd
I think it's only fair to say that very
few administration's in the White House
have underscored the place of the church
in our national life as much as
President Eisenhower has now most of us
are familiar with the faces of the men
around the president but few of us have
had the opportunity to meet the
presidential pastor the man to whom
President Eisenhower listens
every Sunday dr. Elson am I right in
thinking that President Eisenhower has
been spearheading a something of a
religious revival in this country it
would seem to me correct mr. masseur to
report that in America today we observed
two trends on the one hand we have been
participants in spectators in what might
be a described as marked moral
deterioration and say cultural say on
the other hand in America we are
experiencing a great moral resurgence
and spiritual Renaissance and the
president of United States it seems to
me is by his personal example and his
emphasis becoming a symbol of the
incipient spirit spiritual renaissance
of our times we say they said of
riptides a a
decadence on one side and resurgence on
I think they're they parallel each other
there's simultaneous aspects of our
contemporary life their pressures which
probably operate against one another
what are some of the signs of this
decadence dr. Elson I think you the
juvenile delinquency for example the
high incidence of crime the insecurity
of our homes the fragile personalities
the frequency of psychoneurotic
disorders and things of this sort the
sense of insecurity and frustration
amongst people
all of these are evidences it seems to
me of a cultural deterioration I think
part of our emphasis on money-making and
materialistic aspects of our life might
also be emphasized as the evidence on
that hand on the on that side but on the
other hand it seems to me we're in a
rising tide of spiritual recovery we
notice the increased participation in
religious activities on the part of the
laymen there's a new seriousness and
earnestness on the part of college and
university students the quality of the
religious leaders it seems to me is
markedly improved since World War two
the sale of the Bible the fact that
religious books are amongst the
bestsellers a month in and month out the
reappearance of mass evangelism and
effective religion on radio and
television the true because of the fears
of all the threats of war the effects of
atomic bombardment I should say that's
only one of the reasons it would seem to
me that the that some of this does arise
out of a sense of fear fear of the
communists fear of nuclear devices of a
new world war certainly some of it is
due to the fact that we have discovered
the ineptitude of other solutions to the
world's needs and perhaps more basically
than anything else
it is a deep wistfulness in the heart
and soul of men and women to be at home
with their maker for whom their soul was
designed and a part of this revival is
as I imagine renew
church-going more regular habit among
families and people that's true of the
president I think isn't it it seems to
me there's an unprecedented Lehi church
attendance throughout the United States
today not only amongst not only one
religious group but amongst all
religious groups certainly the president
has set a great example for regularity
of church attendance he just doesn't
miss church listen Eddie did you have an
opportunity to meet the president before
he entered the White House yes I had met
the president before he entered the
White House and knew him first as a
general of the army and of course as was
true with every American who served in
the European theater during the war I
was under his command at one time had
been recommended to become the staff
chaplain for the occupation forces in
Germany a position which was not created
and I returned to America to another
position shortly after General
Eisenhower became chief of staff so I
didn't have the privilege of being his
staff chaplain when I ask you this
question do you have any political bias
dr. Elson in favor of one party or the
other may I put it this way how did you
vote in 1952 in 1952 during the election
campaign mrs. Elson and I were on a
lecture tour in the Middle East we
visited some 20 educational institutions
in Egypt and Syrian Lebanon and Jordan
and Israel and elsewhere so that I did
not vote then I pay taxes in California
I pay taxes in the District of Columbia
and I'm one of those disfranchised
Americans who simply cannot vote I
should say this that in the nation's
capital we in the church try to minister
as best we can to people as people with
common religious needs rather than two
people as Democrats and Republicans and
we believe that Washington is is a city
in the world where prayer and the
ministry religion is deeply needed and I
should say that I am among those persons
today who tremendously hopes that
President Eisenhower will succeed and be
a good president of the United States
dr. Elson here in this Christmas season
I wonder whether I could ask your
opinion it recently has been stated in a
very powerful sermon that Christmas has
been sentimentalized here in the United
States do you feel that do you think
something we ought to fight against it
certainly is true that there has been a
great deal of sentimentality attached to
Christmas and perhaps an overemphasis on
some of the secular manifestations of
the Christmas tide observance which have
grown up around the real meaning it
seems to me that the mission of the
church today should be to keep the real
meaning of Christmas alive namely that
it is the commemoration of the birth of
our Lord Jesus Christ it is the
celebration of the incarnation of God
coming into the life of man in the form
of Jesus of Nazareth
incidentally dr. Elson when you write
your sermons are you conscious of any
influence you might be wielding or
exerting on the president in your parish
I should think that any man who
ministers to a congregation in
Washington whether or not the president
the United States was in the
congregation must be deeply aware of the
possible impact which is words either in
prayers or in sermons might have upon
any persons would be in his congregation
though I must confess that I have not
consciously prepared any sermon for any
one person would you kill your sermons
to any particular current news item or
headline I preached the gospel of Jesus
Christ as I understand it have been
taught it I try to enunciate it with
clarity and I should say that no sermon
is prepared to point out a particular
current issue but that if any moral or
spiritual implication is relevant at the
moment I do not dodge it I face it
clearly and speak what I believe to be
the truth of the gospel as pertains to
that part else is an abject heed in
reading the Bible do you find that some
young people read it too much you might
say for the poetry and the literature
that is in it and don't pay enough
attention to the religious truths I
think sometimes that may be said to be
true of young people but I think it is
increasingly true that young people as
well as others are finding the Bible to
be the Word of God and they find God
communicating himself to them
through the words of the Bible it's
nothing dr. Ellison have you decided on
your topic when the president listens to
you it is Christmas time well on last
Sunday December 19th the president was
in the church service and the subject of
my sermon was the Christmas message to
fear and I used as a text I think an
overlooked text sometimes the Christmas
season the text of the herald of the
shepherds
fear not fear not for behold I bring you
good tidings of great joy which shall be
to all people
it seems to me in this fear ridden world
that is one of the messages which the
Christmas tide should bring to us with
deep meaning doctors and the economists
are saying that we're in for a year of
great prosperity do you think that
religion will fare as well as a material
well-being in the coming year my
prediction is that religion is going to
continue on the ascendancy and is going
to absorb a great deal more of more time
and attention on the part of Americans I
believe that the mirror the trek back to
church in itself may not be sufficient
it certainly will the real test of it
will come when people discover those who
are Christians that there is a cross in
their faith that it means sacrifice it
means service and that it costs
something to be a Christian but I
believe the coming year will be a year
of deepening of the spiritual lives of
our people and a recovery and a
reappraisal of our spiritual basis for
the Christmas seasons that you've known
dr. Elson for me and I should think for
most Americans this would be a very very
happy Christmas it is the first in good
many years when American men have
actually not been engaged in armed
combat certainly for me it's a happier
one than 110 years ago when I was
attempting to minister to men in uniform
who were then engaged
in the Battle of the Bulge I remember
with great vividness administering
Communion on Christmas Eve to men who
doubtless received it that night for
their last time certainly this cause for
Thanksgiving this Christmas dr. Elson we
know that the president attended attends
church regularly but do other members of
the cabinet and of the administration
attend your National Presbyterian Church
it is true that a great many of them
attend the National Presbyterian Church
in addition to the president secretary
and mrs. Dulles are part of our
congregation a secretary of mackay of
the Interior Postmaster General
Sommerfeld mr. J Edgar Hoover mr. walter
williams we have two or three assistants
attorney general quite a number of
military officials and justices of the
Supreme Court judges and others but I
think it needs to be said to the
American people that Washington is a
deeply religious City and it's a good
City at least it's just as good as the
people who are sent to it by the rest of
the people of the United States you
don't think that Washington needs
religion more than other parts of the
country then I should say not more than
other parts of the country it needs
religion for the same reason all
Americans and all people whom God has
created need religion thank you very
much dr. Elson it's a tremendous
privilege to have you up here tonight
the opinions expressed on the lawn Jane
crow no scope were those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching crow no scope was Larry
lesser and Auguste texture our
distinguished guest was the Reverend dr.
Edward L R Elston pastor of the National
Presbyterian Church of Washington DC an
important contribution which launched in
Las Vegas has made to the science of
timing was to originate the idea that
sports events should be timed with
identical watches of known and proven
accuracy now to implement this idea
launching created a series of new
watches accurate second by second which
time to a fifth a tenth and a hundredth
of a second in observatory tests these
watches show a degree of accuracy
greater than that required by all
internet
sports and contests associations for
timing world's records the investment of
millions of dollars and years of time in
the development of ever finer timepieces
has resulted in new watch making
principles and methods that have made it
possible to give greater accuracy and
dependability to all launching watches
including the loans in watts which you
now wear on your wrist so when next you
buy a watch out of yourself or as an
important gift remember you may buy a
known or proudly give a long Jean watch
for as little as seventy one fifty lon
gene the world's most honored watch the
world's most honored gift premier
product of the launching with no watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
this is frank night reminding you that
launching and Whitner watches are sold
in service from coast to coast by more
than four thousand leading jewelers who
proudly display this emblems agency for
launching wit nor watchers ad launching
with nor jewelers C Atmos the perpetual
motion clock created by la cultura Atmos
runs without winding without electricity
powered only by variations in the
temperature of the atmosphere
atmospheric of Nicotra division of
launching with Nora
[Music]
the world honored one is Lon Lon gene
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece launching the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the long gene with no watch company it's
time for the launching promise Co a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore watts company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching chrono scope
mr. William Bradford Huie editor of the
american mercury and mr. Paul Martin
Washington bureau chief of the Gannett
News Service our distinguished guests
for this evening is the honorable
Richard be Russell United States Senator
from Georgia the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speakers
senator Russell our audience of course
knows you as a distinguished Georgian
who is now a principal contender for the
Democratic nomination for the presidency
and tonight we welcome some of your
views sir now how long have you been in
the Senate sir I came to the Senate
January 13th 1933 almost 20 years of
coaching and now senator audience would
like to know just where you stand in the
political spectrum are you a new dealer
sir well I call myself a
middle-of-the-road Oh mister here one of
my newspaper friends once labeled me as
a 60% you'd be led during the
administration of President Franklin D
Roosevelt now are you a critic of the
present administration
well I've criticized some of the things
that this administration has done I have
supported though a great deal of the
legislative requests of this
administration I believe senator you
said when you announced for the
presidency that you were a Jeffersonian
Democrat now we haven't heard much about
that lady can you tell us what a
Jeffersonian Democrat surprising to me
it's so few people apparently recall
what Jefferson stood for his fundamental
principles cause he's a father the
Democratic Party he and Andrew Jackson
now patron saint's Jefferson stood for
the rights of the states as being
protection of the rights of the
individual by the federal power he also
stood for absolute incorruptibility in
the administration of government well
senator Russell we hadn't had much of
what he stood for in the Democratic
national platform the last 20 years have
we well we've not won to draw the far
from the fundamental principles of
Jefferson but I think that there are
millions of Democrats throughout the
country that still adhere to the
Jeffersonian principles I think they
live in every state of the Union now sir
in your 20 years and incidentally I
believe you are one of the young
it's men who is a candidate for the
presidents and now you're at only 54
aren't you that's right up in you you've
been in Congress almost 20 years that's
that's true in served as governor my
state before that well sir now in
general did you support most of the
legislation most of the New Deal
legislation under under President
Roosevelt I think that the friend is
estimated I supported 60% of it was
about right and he wrote it very
vigorously a part of this program you
rural electrification program as a farm
program and by any a large number of the
measures that mr. Roosevelt led and the
South has generally prospered under that
and under that legislation is it not yes
I think that the south is in the
prosperity the south is increased
greatly in the last 20 years well on
your definition of the Jeffersonian
Democrat you'd have to have a
considerable revision of say the 1948
Democratic national platform where you
couldn't be an honest exponent of the
party for president well there are some
features of the 1948 platform that I
think a contrary to Jeffersonian
principles not although not all of that
platform was the Democratic Party has
always been the party of the people and
the party of individual rights and
liberties and the party that stood for
the rights of the states well on
practice let's take something in
practice here we've got Democratic
President and White House when we have
had for for about 20 years now
if you were president senator Russell
would you feel that you had the inherent
powers under the Constitution that mr.
Truman says he has to seize the steel
industry or the newspapers or radio
stations or anything else
well mr. Martin I'm afraid of this
matter of inherent powers this is a
government of law and not a government
of men and where there is a statute
that's been enacted by Congress it's
available for use it's highly preferable
to use that statute rather than to
relying on as nebulous a time as
inherent powers of course we must
remember that if the power to seize the
a radio of the press or in
steel plants if that exists in the
president he also has a power to cease
the labor unions and the labor man would
feel rather alarm to come in and find
some major sitting in me at the desk of
the business agent or the secretary
treasurer of the Union now that you are
telling our audience that you are
somewhat disturbed by the president's
acts I would much prefer it for the
president to have followed the statutes
I think there at least two statutes that
could have been employed to resolve this
matter without resorting to inherent
powers now there's a fear the precedent
that's been said I don't think miss
Truman's in a dictator but I think that
his act could well be the blueprint for
some man well who might seize all of the
laws of government in the future on the
statute you mean the national emergency
Clause of the taft-hartley Act yes
either that all a statue of which I
haven't had been no author when the
original draft bill passed which gave
the president the power to seize any
plant or facility in this country that
failed or refused to supply contracts
that were necessary for the defense
effort I think has been preferable to
the audio one and both of them provide
the standards of seizure they provide
for the method of repayment and don't
leave all of those matters up in the air
is just matter interesting of the
inherent powers now Senator Russell this
matter of inherent powers you know it's
another southerner Tom Clark of Texas
used to be the Attorney General who
ruled and told the president that he
hadn't here at cars under the
Constitution and Tom Clark's now on the
Supreme Court which would be the court
of last resort if anybody ever wanted to
test this theory of inherent powers well
mr. modern of course each lawyer suppose
thinks his opinion is best had been a
number of a decision which majority this
present Supreme Court have handed down
and it did not jibe with my construction
of the Constitution of the United States
senator after all now you
our very active candidate for the
Democratic nomination for the presidency
so rapidly we'd like some of your views
on specific issues now number one about
how many delegates do you expect to have
at the convention in Chicago well I hope
to have a as many as 400 and I'm quite
confident that I will have more than 300
and and and I think that our audience is
particularly interested do you expect to
have support from northern states I will
have some support from northern states
yes I will have some delegates however
the book of my support is in the
southern states now the delegate is a
delegate in one vote counts as much as
well that matters as a practical
politician do you think that it is now
possible for a southerner to receive the
Democratic nomination for the presidency
I don't like to think that after 90
years of intervene and the Democratic
Party has loyally supported the been
loyally supported by the south over that
period that day a man will be
discriminated against because we haven't
have been born on the wrong side of the
tracks and that brings light of the
mason-dixon line that brings us to the
principle question sir which you are
always asked I'm sure but our audience
would like to hear your views on the
traditional policies as regards FPPC now
that of course is one of the things that
there's object that's reasons that
you're objected to in the northern
cities particularly just what is your
view on fppc well mr. here the FPPC
isn't any southern is your sectionally
sure it goes there to the very heart of
our American system it it if that theory
contemplates that the federal government
has the power to pass upon employment
and upon promotion and upon employment
policies and they also in the matter of
discharges from employment now I do not
believe the free enterprise system can
possibly exist if we had have a horde of
federal agents running all over the
country appearing over men's shoulders
and undertaking to read their minds
course after all it is a matter the
thought was to thought police what was
in the man's
when he hired this individual rather
than the other or even a group rather
than other group I do not think I think
that that will eventually result in the
nationalization of all business industry
in this country if we have a past of
compulsory jail sentence or FPPC that
puts a man in prison because he employs
one man instead of another now it's not
a socialist American issue this is very
important issue but while we have time
you I'd like to discuss on about foreign
policy you're you were the chairman of
the joint Senate Armed Services and
foreign relations committee that
conducted the hearings on President
Truman's firing of General MacArthur
advisor well you went into that very
exhaustively about so many awards of
tests of about seven weeks morning and
afternoon or any night sessions well now
why didn't you ever get around to
writing a report telling the American
people how you felt about whether the
president should or should not a fire
General in the contact well I'll tell
you about that to every American citizen
had made up his mind already
there was no reason therefore that
committee to sit down and squabble for
three weeks in writing a report which
would have been a divided report had
been impossible for all of them to have
agreed and it would have just added fuel
to the flames of bitterness that spread
over the country on both sides of that
issue we the committee couldn't restore
General MacArthur to his command if we
had held that the president had been in
error in discharging him and there was
no good that I saw that could flow from
the committee undertaking by a division
to say well the General MacArthur was
right over the Joint Chiefs were right
or the president well it sounds a
reaction his views it's been a great
pleasure to have you with us tonight and
thank you very much sir thank you for
the opportunity to be on this probe
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching Cronus Coke was mr.
William Bradford Huie
and mr. Paul Martin our distinguished
guests was the honorable richard be
Russell United States Senator from
Georgia
the progress of watchmaking over the
years has been enormous li stimulated by
competitions between watchmakers
arranged by some of the leading national
observatories you should know that a
first prize won in an observatory
accuracy contest is one of the highest
honors to which a watch manufacturer can
aspire you should also know if you are
contemplating the purchase of a very
fine watch that the record of launching
in observatory accuracy competitions is
unsurpassed
year after year since 1878 lawn gene
watches have won first prize after first
prize for chronometer x' deck watches
pocket watches and wristwatches and of
great interest to you the present
accuracy record for wristwatches at the
great national government observatory is
held by launching the world's most
honored watch if you wish to own just
about the finest watch made anywhere in
the world
your choice might well be launching the
world's most honored watch winner of 10
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medal awards and innumerable honors
for accuracy in fields of precise timing
launching the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn jean wit
nor watch company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
[Music]
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host Frank Knight inviting you
to join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene Khurana scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honoured Longy sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches
[Music]